[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers guten
abend hinein das wirklich allerletzte
was die welt jetzt brauchen könnte wäre
eine weitere verheerende militärische
eskalation
diesmal im pazifik aber die angst davor
ist da und das hängt zusammen mit einem
staatsbesuch der keiner sein darf der
auffällig unauffällig daher kommt und
gerade rund um den globus eilmeldungen
produziert eine kleine us
regierungsmaschine ist heute nachmittag
unserer zeit in taiwan gelandet kein
roter teppich kein großer aufmarsch es
ist kaum etwas zu erkennen
die dame in rosa kostüm gerade noch so
das ist nancy pelosi sprecherin des us
repräsentantenhauses
immerhin nummer drei nach präsident und
vize präsidentin sie besuchte ein land
um das nicht nur die usa seit
jahrzehnten einen diplomatischen
eiertanz machen taiwan ist
265 mal kleiner als china liegt nur 160
kilometer entfernt von china und ist
anders als china eine lebhafte
demokratie
wirtschaftlich immens erfolgreich
liberal kreativ ein gegenentwurf zur
polit diktatur in peking und auch
deshalb den machthaber dort ein dorn im
auge der pelosi besuch ist für china ein
spiel mit dem feuer peking droht mit
zitat gezielten militärischen aktionen
ulf röller
nancy pelosi bekommt die große eskorte
als sie durch die straßen fährt für
taiwan ist dieser besuch der us
spitzenpolitikerin wie eine
lebensversicherung in der
auseinandersetzung mit china es liegt
spannung in der luft
dafür hat das chinesische militär am
morgen mit solchen videos gesorgt die
sie heute veröffentlichen ein volk und
seine soldaten zum kampf bereit
ich bin soldat brüllen sie ich gehorche
der kommunistischen partei ich werde das
volk verteidigen
die chinesische armee probt den
ernstfall auch für eine invasion taiwans
unsere kampfjets sind um unsere insel
taiwan geflogen um die souveränität und
unser territorium zu sichern
am abend bedankt sich taiwan bei amerika
willkommen vorsitzende pelosi leuchtet
auf
noch vor wenigen tagen mussten die
taiwanesen den ernstfall proben ein
angriff der chinesin auf irland und die
flucht in den bunker die angst vor dem
krieg prägt den alltag
wir müssen uns vorbereiten wenn es krieg
gibt
morgen wird taiwans präsident in nancy
pelosi treffen deren besuch treibt die
weltmächte china amerika in eine tiefe
krise die usa sehen sich als schutzmacht
in einer region die china als ihren
hinterhof bezeichnet die antwort der
chinesen ließ nicht lange auf sich
warten das verteidigungsministerium
kündigt eine viertägige militärübung an
in der taiwan umzingelt wird
eins ist klar die usa sind dafür
verantwortlich und sie werden einen
preis dafür zahlen chinas souveränität
untergraben zu haben
der konflikt zwischen china und taiwan
hat eine blutige geschichte im
bürgerkrieg kämpfte man gegen chang kai
chen der floh vor den kommunisten mit
seinem truppen nach taiwan
präsident sieht sich als nachfolger von
mao sieht die vereinigung mit taiwan als
seine historie der mission notfalls mit
militärischer gewalt
wir werden keine machtmittel
ausschließen und halten uns alle
optionen offen so wollen wir
sicherstellen dass es keine
einflussnahme von außen gibt
vor der küste taiwans belauern sich
china und die usa es ist ein duell der
weltmächte
der us flugzeugträger ronald reagan ist
nun unterwegs in der region keiner will
hier an einfluss verlieren
sollte china eine krise anzetteln oder
die situation eskalieren lassen dann ist
peking daran schuld wir erwarten von
ihnen sich verantwortungsvoll zu
verhalten
nancy pelosi winkt nach der landung es
ist eine freundliche geste in einer
frostigen region
die usa und taiwan sind verbündete aber
merkwürdige es gibt keine offiziellen
botschaften die us-vertretung in taipeh
nennt sich amerikanisches institut es
gibt keine treffen höchstens mal
verschämte telefonate alles um china
bloß nicht zu verärgern und jetzt fliegt
nancy pelosi hin el mati wissen
beobachtet für uns das ganze haus
washington genannt elmer wie gefährlich
ist denn dieser besuch aus sicht des
weißen hauses
es kann brandgefährlich sein und das hat
damit zu tun dass man hier analysiert
hat zu welchen schlüssen denn peking
gekommen ist aus der ukraine krise aus
dem ukraine krieg hat man ja zu sehen
können wie schwer sich russland getan
hat die ukraine zu erobern das hat nicht
geklappt und sich gewissermaßen jetzt
fest gefräst hat gegen eine vom westen
hochgerüstete ukraine und es gibt ja
eine analyse die besagt dass china eben
daraus die schlussfolgerung ziehen
könnte man müsse lieber früher als
später taiwan angreifen um zu verhindern
dass man nachher auf einen gegner trifft
der massiv hochgerüstet wird durch die
usa durch andere verbündete in der
region und dann würde so ein besuch wie
jetzt der ein passender vorwand sein das
ist jedenfalls die sorge man hofft aber
gleichzeitig eben auch klar zu machen
dass china damit eine menge porzellan
zerschlagen würde die usa nancy pelosi
in diesem fall auch weil durch eine
militärische eskalation natürlich am
ende eine zweite front entsteht neben
der eu keine kriegt das bündnis zwischen
russland und china noch enger wird das
massive wirtschaftliche folgen für
jahren rund um alle staaten der welt hat
weil diese region für den handel sehr
wichtig ist und damit auch jede
zusammenarbeit beendet wäre bei so
wichtigen themen wie kampf gegen den
klimawandel oder gegen pandemien also
man appelliert ein stück weiter in china
sich zu überlegen ob es das wirklich
wert ist wenn man dann lieber nochmal
moment über die politische nummer drei
in den usa nancy pelosi ist seit langem
eine kritikerin der chinesischen
regierung wir können uns das mal
anschauen hier sehen wir sie 1991 schon
auf dem des himmlischen friedens in
peking wo sie eine fahne entrollt zum
gedenken an das massaker dort ist das
der grund weshalb sie sich jetzt auch
nicht abbringen ließ jetzt taiwan zu
besuchen
also es spielt eine große rolle aber sie
fühlt sich natürlich dabei bestärkt von
politikern der demokratischen und
republikanischen partei denn alle sehen
ja seit monaten zu wie china sich
jedenfalls scheinbar schon warm läuft
für einen angriff auf taiwan will man
bei spielen denn letztes jahr im oktober
hat china 50 kampfjets in die neutrale
zone vor taiwan geschickt und hat
provoziert kurz darauf hat joe biden
dann mit schinken gesprochen telefonisch
man hat sich geschworen dass man
gegenseitig dieser ein-china-politik
respektieren will aber nur wenige tage
später hat sie dann eine flammende rede
in china gehalten und klargemacht dass
taiwan am ende teil chinas sein wird und
dass jeder der sich dem entgegen steht
untergehen wird also man rechnet damit
dass über kurz oder lang china die
gelegenheit nutzen wird ein angriff auf
taiwan zu starten und die us-regierung
hofft natürlich dass diese
auseinandersetzung jetzt nicht jetzt
passiert nur weil eine politikerin so
spielt man das hier herunter jetzt eben
taipeh besucher immer herzlichen dank
morgen dann die politischen gespräche
von nancy pelosi in taiwan da wollen wir
natürlich weiter berichten und weitere
hintergründe zu dem jahrzehntealten
konflikt nachher hier im heute-journal
update und wir bleiben noch einen moment
in den usa wo präsident joe biden ein
signal der stärke senden wollte
ungewöhnlicherweise vom balkon des booms
im weißen haus weil er immer noch corona
positiv ist es soll auch ein zeichen
sein dass die usa nicht aufhören werden
die zu verfolgen die sie verantwortlich
machen für schlimmste terror taten wie
die anschläge vom 11 september und dass
amerika zu schlagen können ohne selbst
vor ort zu sein ayman al zawahiri
anführer des terrornetzwerks al qaida
wurde in kabul getötet ferngesteuert
durch eine amerikanische kampfdrohne
claudia bates mit mehr dazu
most wanted das fbi fahndungsplakat
eines der meistgesuchten terroristen ist
bereits aktualisiert dies ist gestorben
der rauch über einem haus in kabul soll
den zugriff am frühen sonntagmorgen
zeigen laut us geheimdienst hatte der
chef der terrororganisation al-kaida in
der afghanischen hauptstadt bei seiner
frau und tochter unterschlupf gefunden
das haus habe er nie verlassen sich aber
regelmäßig auf dem balkon aufgehalten
dort sei er mit zwei raketen aus einer
drohne beschossen worden sechs monate
lang hatte der us geheimdienst in
absprache mit präsident biden die
operation geplant
der gerechtigkeit wurde genüge getan
diesen terroristenführer gibt es nicht
mehr die menschheit muss diesen
teuflischen mörder nicht mehr fürchten
die usa zeigen weiterhin
entschlossenheit und unsere fähigkeit
das amerikanische volk gegen die zu
verteidigen die uns schaden wollen
einmal als aber hier ii war über
jahrzehnte zunächst der mann hinter
osama bin laden der chefstratege von al
qaida der architekt der verheerenden
terroranschläge vom 11 september 2001
beim angriff auf das kriegsschiff uss
cole im jahr 2000 mit 17 toten soldaten
hatte er ebenso eine schlüsselrolle wie
bei den anschlägen auf die us
botschaften in kenia und tansania 1998
bei denen mehr als 200 menschen getötet
wurden
ganz gleich wie lange es dauert und wo
ihr euch versteckt wenn ihr unser volk
bedroht werden wir euch finden und außer
gefecht setzen
bereits nach dem chaotischen abzug der
us-truppen aus afghanistan hatte
präsident biden darauf gestanden gegen
alle kritik die usa könnten den
anti-terror-kampf auch aus der ferne
fortsetzen ohne soldaten im land
experten sehen dies bestätigt
der geheimdienst konnte die richtigen
informationen gewinnen und konnte al
sawahiri kriegen ohne das andere zu
schaden kamen das war ein gut geplantes
und durchgeführtes ausschalten eines
terroristen
unter als er war hier hatten sich in
vielen ländern regionaler ableger von
al-qaida gebildet die er nicht
kontrollieren konnte
der schlag ist daher eher von
symbolischer als von operativer
bedeutung die wahre bedrohung in
afghanistan wenn wir von international
und extremismus sprechen ist der
afghanische arm des die curasan gruppe
die taliban-führung muss gewusst haben
dass al-sawahiri in kabul war nach us
erkenntnissen gehörte das haus in dem er
sich aufhielt einem engen mitarbeiter
des afghanischen innenministers hakkani
selbst chef eines terrornetzwerks vor
dem us abzug hatten die taliban zugesagt
mit al qaida zu brechen die usa sehen
dieses abkommen nun verletzt
oder sind wir schon wieder und haben
jetzt natürlich weitere wichtige
nachrichten hat er nämlich mit blick auf
die weitere nachrichten
russlands oberster gerichtshof hat das
ukrainische asaf regiment als terror
organisation eingestuft mit folgen für
die mitglieder des regiments die sich
aktuell in russischer
kriegsgefangenschaft befinden diesen
drohen nun jahrelange haftstrafen
kämpfer das also auf regiments hatten
lange im stahlwerk in der hafenstadt
mario pohl ausgeharrt das regiment ist
wegen seiner rechtsextremen wurzeln
umstritten
wegen der gasknappheit hat die spanische
regierung strenge maßnahmen beschlossen
um energie zu sparen in allen
öffentlichen gebäuden sollen künftig die
klimaanlagen heruntergedreht werden
gleiches geld etwa für hotels büros oder
geschäfte das bedeutet dass im sommer
nur noch auf 27 grad abgekühlt werden
darf und im winter soll höchstens auf 19
grad geheizt werden außerdem sollen
abends die lichter ausgehen das betrifft
zum beispiel schaufenster im
einzelhandel und sehenswürdigkeiten die
konservative opposition hat bereits
widerstand angekündigt
in frankreich rückt die abschaffung der
rundfunkgebühren er nach der
nationalversammlung hat nun auch der
senat in erster lesung einen
gesetzentwurf der regierung zugestimmt
wonach der öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk künftig über die mehrwertsteuer
finanziert werden soll der senat würde
diese regelung jedoch bis 2024 befristen
und fordert bis dahin eine echte reform
zu erarbeiten
dadurch sollen nach angaben der
regierungen die bürger entlastet werden
vor dem oberlandesgericht frankfurt hat
heute der prozess gegen einen
mutmaßlichen rechtsextremisten begonnen
die bundesanwaltschaft wirft dem 20
jährigen marvin die vorbereitung einer
schweren staatsgefährdenden gewalttat
vor der angeklagte soll anschläge mit
sprengsätzen und schusswaffen geplant
und gegen das waffen- und
sprengstoffgesetz verstoßen haben zudem
wird ihm die versuchte gründung der
terrororganisation
atomwaffen division vorgeworfen
im ehemaligen vernichtungslager
auschwitz birkenau wurde heute der
hunderttausenden sinti und roma gedacht
die von den nationalsozialisten ermordet
wurden der vorsitzende des zentralrats
deutscher sinti und roma romani rose
mahnte den wieder erstarkenden
antiziganismus zu echten
bundesratspräsident ramelow sprach von
einer art unausgesprochene apartheid
durch die die angehörigen von europas
grösster minderheit vielerorts an den
rand gedrängt werden
der krieg gegen die ukraine der uns hier
seit monaten berührt und beschäftigt ist
in russland selbst merkwürdig abwesend
die staatsmedien erzählen ihre helden
geschichte einer spezialoperation wobei
ukrainische opfer und grausamkeiten an
der zivilbevölkerung genauso wenig
vorkommen wie das wort krieg in den
sozialen medien setzt der kreml
geschickt auf emotionen und subtile
einflussnahme ergebnis die mehrheit in
russland bemüht sich laut westlichen
wissenschaftlern kaum noch romanen
abgleich der medialen berichterstattung
mit der realität andere versuchen so
verdrängen und alles negative einfach
auszublenden
heute feiert russland den tag der
luftlandetruppen aus moskau für bürger
für ihre söhne wünscht sich irina eine
zukunft bei der ami zumal russland ja
gerade friedliche zeiten durchleben bis
auf diese militär operation wie sie sagt
ich bin der auffassung dass die ukraine
nicht unser feind ist auf jeden fall
irgendwie ist es zu dieser situation
gekommen
ausgelassen feiern russlands
luftlandetruppen sich heute selbst der
brutale kampf der kameraden in der
ukraine drückt die stimmung nicht
merklich linientreue feier laune
meine ehefrau ist aus der ukraine daher
ist dies für mich sehr nahe und
schmerzhaft aber ich betone dort kämpft
man nicht gegen das ukrainische volk
dort erfolgt eine militärische
sonderoperation gegen das ukrainische
regime
es ist die offizielle erzählung wie
putin und die propaganda sie stetig
wiederholen sie verfängt in weiten
teilen der bevölkerung und macht es
leichter weg zu sehen zu verdrängen den
sommer zu genießen
das russische soldaten in der ukraine
töten und sterben im moskauer alltag
scheint es keine rolle zu spielen
hängt diese situation von mir ab nichts
hängt von mir ab und nichts hängt von
dir ab wir können nur beobachten auf das
ergebnis und die veränderungen warten
ich warte auf den sieg
russische gelassenheit während die
staatsführung das nachbarland zerstört
und dafür sanktionen in kauf nimmt die
die eigene zukunft aufs spiel setzen
beim unabhängigen umfrage institute
levada versuchen sie antworten auf die
scheinbare gleichgültigkeit zu finden
wird wer ist schuld an den opfern und
der zerstörung haben wir gefragt auf dem
ersten platz kam die nato auf dem
zweiten weit abgeschlagen die ukraine
und russland war in keiner weise schuld
das befreit von dem gedanken daran dass
gerade ein bruderkrieg stattfindet
jede kritik am militärischen vorgehen
könnte bestraft werden die
repressionsmaschine des russischen
staates ist nicht zu übersehen im juli
bezeichnet marina ob sie an ecover putin
als mörder weil sie anti kriegs parolen
rief und postete laufen gleich mehrere
verfahren gegen sie
sie haben jetzt viele freunde rufen mich
an und sagen ob gott wieso hast du dich
darauf eingelassen sie werden dich platt
machen auffressen über den haufen werfen
und töten wir unterstützen diesen krieg
auch nicht aber wir schweigen lieber
warten ab sind abgetaucht
ob bequemes schulterzucken oder
ängstliches abwarten während in der
ukraine gekämpft wird ergibt man sich in
russlands hauptstadt dem schicksal
bemerkenswert dieser blick aus russland
auf die welt jetzt nochmal hanna mit
einem thema das jeder hier und jedem von
uns zunehmend auch im alltag begegnet
eine immer größer werdende
herausforderung christian für firmen
wird es immer schwerer qualifizierte
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter zu
finden fast jedes zweite unternehmen
klagt laut einer umfrage des ifo
instituts über fachkräftemangel das ist
ein neuer höhepunkt stefanie bareth
welche bereiche betrifft das am meisten
also das thema fachkräftemangel
erstreckt sich ja eigentlich über alle
branchen aber die unterschiede sind dann
bei näherer betrachtung doch recht
deutlich am stärksten betroffen ist die
dienstleistungsbranche hier tritt es die
zeitarbeit sowie steuerberater und
wirtschaftsprüfer etwa am härtesten
einzelhandel und baugewerbe beklagen ja
schon lange dramatische personalengpässe
und am besten schneiden auch die chemie
und die pharmaindustrie ab es mangelt an
allen ecken und enden allein dem
handwerk fehlen laut verband eine
viertelmillion qualifizierter
arbeitskräfte und bis zu 20.000
ausbildungsplätze bleiben jährlich
unbesetzt immer mehr unternehmen müssen
ihre geschäfte sogar einschränken weil
sie einfach nicht genug personal finden
die korona krise hat diesen trend
beschleunigt denn einmal abgewanderte
fachkräfte kommen nicht wieder zurück in
die alten jobs das spüren vor allem das
hotel und gastgewerbe aber auch die
luftfahrtbranche wie es urlauber derzeit
an deutschlands flughäfen mehr erleben
müssen was sind denn die genauen gründe
für den fachkräftemangel die gründe sind
vielfältig natürlich und obwohl jetzt
nach der pandemie wieder viel mehr
menschen arbeiten viele mitarbeiter
sogar über das rentenalter hinaus tätig
sind es reicht einfach nicht das liegt
zunächst natürlich am demografischen
wandel die jahrgänge die jetzt in rente
gehen sind einfach größer als die
nachfolgenden frühzeitiges ausscheiden
aus dem arbeitsleben also etwa die rente
mit 63 haben die fachkräftelücke
ebenfalls vergrößert und auch der trend
zum studium wird sich negativ aus dem
handwerk ist es auch im einfach kaum
gelungen junge menschen ausreichend für
vach berufe zu begeistern
image und natürlich auch bezahlung sind
nach einem studium in oft attraktiver
vielen dank stefanie nach frankfurt
gut drei monate nach den ersten affen
pocken fällen in deutschland haben sich
laut robert koch institut erstmals zwei
jugendliche mit dem virus infiziert
insgesamt wurden dem rk ii mittlerweile
2724 infektionen gemeldet die
übertragungen übertragung erfolge vor
allem durch sexuellen kontakt unter
männern der vorsitzende des
weltärztebund montgomery forderte nun
gegenüber dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland eine bessere aufklärung über
das virus mit kurzen ist in europa ein
impfstoff gegen die affen talken
zugelassen
eine gute nachricht aus den
waldbrandgebieten im osten deutschlands
das feuer im süden brandenburgs konnte
laut feuerwehr gelöscht werden es war in
der vergangenen woche ausgebrochen und
hatte sich schnell auf etwa 800 hektar
ausgebreitet noch keine entwarnung
dagegen in der sächsischen schweiz dort
gehen die löscharbeiten weiter
die mitbegründerin des senioren
schutzbundes und der partei graue
panther trude unruh ist tot wie jetzt
bekannt wurde ist die ehemalige
bundestagsabgeordnete bereits im
vergangenen november im alter von 96
jahren gestorben
als aktivistin für die rechte älterer
menschen machte sie sich ab den 70er
jahren einen namen für die grünen saß
sie parteilose kandidatin drei jahre im
bundestag und kämpfte unter anderem für
eine grundrente
man wird ja wohl noch träumen dürfen
speziell in diesen zeiten und vermutlich
ist das was manche jetzt gleich als
utopische fantasterei abtun werden
tatsächlich wichtiger denn je in diesen
zeiten unsere filmkritikerin sabine
schulz nimmt uns jetzt mit in die wüste
sinai in diese
atemberaubende biblische landschaft zu
zwei männern und einem kamel und einer
deutschen kino komödie die viel erzählt
über die wunderbare macht von
überraschenden begegnungen genau das was
wir jetzt brauchen können
es ist ein kurioser trip durch die wüste
sinai die geschichte einer wundersamen
freundschaft
alles beginnt in jerusalem ben ist
gerade aus new york gelandet im ultra
orthodoxen viertel mehr sherin soll er
verkuppelt werden doch dann sieht er
eine chance der arrangierten heirat zu
entkommen ich brauche ja noch jemanden
für alexandria wir sind die älteste
jüdische gemeinde in der diaspora und
jetzt sind wir nur noch zu neunt wenn
sie nicht bis breisach den zehnten mann
finden fällt alles an digital ich kannte
ihn nur noch sechs tage bis zum
jüdischen pessach fest die zeit drängt
als er den flug verpasst entscheidet
sich der weltfremde ben allzu naiv für
den landweg
[Musik]
was in den nachrichten verpasst nicht
alle araber im bus sind begeistert von
ben
mitten in der wüste ist für ihn
endstation
doch wie vereint mann jüdischen glaubens
regeln und rituale mit den archaischen
gesetzen der wüste
hauptdarsteller lukas g ein glücksfall
für den film auch als experte für
jüdisch religiöse fragen
ich bin selbst in einer katholischen
gemeinde in brooklyn aufgewachsen ich
mit 22 verlassen habe darum konnte ich
das filmteam auch beraten die kleidung
die ich im film trage ist meine eigene
auch der hund
um noch rechtzeitig nach alexandria zu
kommen ist ein möglicher beduine bands
letzte hoffnung
ich fahr dich aber erst muss ich meinen
kamel finden doch dann geht alles schief
nicht nur die fatale autopanne
religionen und vorurteile prallen
aufeinander und die feindbilder der
ganzen region es gibt von uns die wollen
gar kein israel bevor der misst sich
kommt und die bomben auf gaza das sind
nicht wir in den meiner sprache gibt es
nicht mal ein wort für für pakete oder
kampfjet also wäre die schweiz
doch je besser sie einander kennen
lernen desto größer nähe und respekt
heute mag dein gott mein brot
heute ist das geschah weil ich beim
kochen mit gemacht habe wie du ihnen
sagen
wenn jemand mit dir ist gibt es keinen
streit
gibt es freundschaft
schon im großen und ganzen die erfahrung
da unten gemacht also dass speziell die
ganz normalen menschen die einfachen
leute die taxifahrer auf der einen oder
anderen seite die haben miteinander kein
problem und das ist noch das universelle
wenn menschen sich begegnen auf eine
menschliche art dann gibt es selten
probieren
und kein wasser im brunnen ist
dann ist das unser last supper
wir die wüsten odyssee in einer
freundschaft gipfelt die über jedem
glauben steht zeigt dieser film mit
märchenhaften charme und augenzwinkern
[Musik]
nicht ganz koscher ist eine göttliche
eine köstliche komödie amüsant
nachdenklich und voller hoffnung
[Musik]
nicht ganz koscher kinostart ist
übermorgen wie unendlich wichtig einfach
begegnungen sind das kann man ja nicht
oft genug zeigen gerade in einer region
wie dem nahen osten wo den menschen eben
diese begegnungen von den mächtigen dort
immer schwerer gemacht werden
sogleich nach uns ganz besonderes
reportage fernsehen die kolleginnen und
kollegen von 37 grad haben ein ganzes
jahr lang daran gearbeitet
es ist eine doku auf die man sich
einlassen muss und sollte ich bin viele
als sie und zeigt wie sich das anfühlt
wenn man in sich zwölf verschiedene
persönlichkeiten wahrnimmt jetzt gleich
hier im zdf
und später gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update gegen 0.15 mit
christopher wehrmann vom gesamten team
hier bei uns in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt kommt die dritte
hitzewelle und ähnlich wie die
vorangegangenen ist es eigentlich mehr
so ein hitze höhepunkt nicht länger als
ein zwei tage wo kommt die hitzewelle
her natürlich wieder aus richtung
iberische halbinsel und der hitze
höhepunkt wird bei uns in deutschland am
donnerstag erreicht die kommende nacht
wird noch einigermaßen frisch zumindest
mal am alpenrand und auch in der
oberpfalz sinken die werte auf 12 grad
bis 19 grad geht es im rhein-main-gebiet
rotter die nacht wird meist klar sein
nur in norddeutschland gibt es ein paar
wolkenfelder und ähnlich sieht es morgen
auch über tagaus meist strahlt die sonne
vom blauen himmel in norddeutschland
gibt es einige quellwolken die bringen
wenig schatten und keinen regen und so
wird's heiß bei uns die temperaturen
klettern morgen auf 30 bis 36 grad und
nur an der nordsee ist es bei 28 29 grad
etwas weniger heiß und am donnerstag
wird es dann noch eine spur heißer 38 39
grad erwarten wir hier zum beispiel
richtung lausitz im südlichen
brandenburg auch in sachsen anhalt und
an mittel und an oberhalb das gute daran
ist es geht schnell vorbei mit dieser
großen hitze denn schon zum wochenende
sehen sie wie die temperaturen sich
wieder normalisieren an der küste sind
es dann nur noch so 20 21 grad und in
süddeutschland immerhin sommerliche 25
bis 29 grad also ist auch nicht mehr so
heiss ganz geräuschlos geht dieses
abräumen der hitze allerdings nicht
vonstatten wenn es in kräftige gewitter
unterwegs die am freitag zunächst die
mitte betreffen am samstag dann auch den
alpen rats guten abend